this is what I don't like I'm just going
to be honest with you you called with
the issue George just freed you up a
good chunk of money but that's an excuse
you put an excuse in there he's solving
your problem for you and you can't say
yeah but you've got to go okay that gets
me one step closer what's the next thing
I gotta do okay that gets me Next Step
Closer that's the type of attitude we
need here Zane to get this done you've
got to be looking at this going all
right great check what's next okay good
I'll do that I'll do whatever it takes
to clear this debt that's where you've
got to be right now and I I think George
was right before you guys were coasting
and you were just going along and and
now you're gonna have to really put the
pedal to the metal and you're gonna have
to you're gonna feel this there's no
getting out of a 100K of debt without
feeling it and without it hurting